Vamos a seguir resolviendo problemas de porcentajes
y en este problema lo voy a empezar así.
Imagínate que yo tengo 50 pesos en mi billetera...
vamos a apuntarlo, esto es muy importante...
tengo 50 pesos en mi billetera y me voy a
una tienda comercial.
Y cuando llego a la tienda me dan la buena
noticia de que el día de hoy todo está al
25% de descuento, todo está al 25% de descuento
del precio del mercado, es decir, el precio de venta.
Y bueno, ya que yo tengo estos 50 pesos, me
pregunto lo siguiente, para no buscar en vano,
sería bastante bueno saber,
¿cuál es el mayor precio que puedo pagar?
Es decir, contando que tengo 50 pesos en mi
billetera y que todo está al 25% de descuento.
Así que para resolver este problema, lo primero
que voy a hacer es definir a "x", precisamente
como ese precio, sea "x" igual al precio más
grande que puedo pagar con estos 50 pesos...
al precio más grande que pueda pagar...
date cuenta que si por ejemplo,
algo está en la tienda departamental a 100 pesos, cuando le aplicamos el descuento entonces el precio
final va a ser de 75 pesos, es decir, cualquier
producto tiene el 25% de descuento,
ahora bien, si nos fijamos en este producto que
estoy buscando y este producto valía "x"
antes del descuento, cuando yo le aplico el
descuento le vamos a quitar el 25% del precio
de este producto y esto es lo que va a ser
nuestro precio de venta, pero "x" menos el
25% de "x", pues si nosotros lo vemos en su
forma decimal, nos quedaría como "x" menos
el .25 de "x", porque recuerda que el 25%
lo podemos escribir en su forma decimal,
como .25 por "x", "x" menos ".25x", que por cierto, "x" es "1x" y "1x" menos ".25x" esto es lo mismo que ".75x".
Y bueno, éste es nuestro precio de venta
y nuestro precio de venta ya con el descuento,
es decir, que el día de hoy que esta tienda
comercial está de oferta, todo lo vende al
75% o dicho de otra manera, al .75 del precio original.
Pero bueno, yo solamente tengo 50 pesos en
mi billetera, sería un poco decepcionante
fijarme en cosas que sean muy caras y no
poderlas comprar,
por lo tanto yo lo que quiero saber para
buscar mucho más rápido es,
¿cuál es el precio máximo sin descuento en el cual me puedo fijar para que yo pueda pagar al final 50 pesos?
Eso quiere decir que ".75x" sea igual a mis
50 pesos que traigo en mi billetera, el 75%
del valor original del producto que voy a comprar, tiene que ser igual a todo lo que traigo que son 50 pesos.
Y entonces, de aquí ya podemos despejar a "x".
Si yo divido ambos lados de la ecuación entre
.75, me va a quedar 50 entre .75 y ya con
esto obtengo el valor de "x", es decir, el
máximo precio que yo puedo pagar en este
centro comercial, así que vamos a hacerlo.
.75 divide a 50.0000
y voy a recorrer el punto a la derecha 2 lugares,
entonces me va a quedar el punto justo aquí y entonces realmente 50 entre .75 es lo mismo que 5000 entre 75,
esta división ya es mucho más fácil de hacerla,
no está de más recordar que primero
hay que quitar el punto decimal.
Bueno, 75 en 50 no cabe, pero 75 en 500 si
cabe, 75 por 2 es 150, así que cabe como
unas 6 veces, entonces vamos a poner aquí
6 veces y vamos a ver qué es lo que pasa.
De hecho 7 veces no cabe, entonces 6, 6 por
5 son 30 y llevamos 3 y después me queda
6 por 7 = 42, 42 más 3 es 45 y entonces cuando
hago la diferencia de estos dos, me queda 50
y creo que ya estás viendo el patrón
porque aquí otra vez se baja un 0 y entonces
si borrar todo pues me quedaría que otra
vez cabe 6 veces y después 6 por 75 es 450
y después cuando yo hago la resta me queda
50 y así sucesivamente...
es decir, que me va a quedar 6.66666666, el
valor de "x" que estoy buscando es de 66.666666
y darle 66.6666666 pesos, por lo tanto vamos
a redondearlo a centavos, 66.67 centavos
o dicho de otra manera, pues esto es lo mismo que
66.666 periódico, esto si queremos dar una
respuesta completamente exacta o en su dado
caso pues ya sabemos que .6666 periódico
es lo mismo que 2/3, entonces me quedaría
66 enteros 2/3, pero bueno, realmente la respuesta
correcta es 66.67, es un redondeo a centavos
para que lo podamos pagar en caja.
Es decir, que con mis 50 pesos, yo puedo comprar
cualquier artículo que valga 66.67 pesos,
si le aplicamos el 25% de descuento en esta
tienda departamental, si yo encuentro unos
lentes que valen 66.65 pesos, los puedo comprar,
pero si yo encuentro una gorra que vale 100 pesos
pues entonces no la puedo comprar.
Pero bueno, vamos a hacer otro ejercicio que
tenga que ver igual con dinero.
Así que imagínate que inicialmente,
tenemos 100 pesos...
Este es un ejercicio rápido, vamos a ver
si lo puedes contestar de una manera muy rápida.
Tengo 100 pesos y entonces los meto al banco
por 1 año y el banco me da un crecimiento del 25%.
Perfecto, en un año mi dinero aumenta en
un 25%, pero el siguiente año pasa algo muy
trágico, en lugar de ganar o de que mi dinero
aumente va a disminuir.
Esta vez mi dinero se va a encoger en un 25%,
son los riesgos de invertir con el dinero,
a veces se gana, a veces se pierde.
Y bueno, la pregunta es,
¿cuánto dinero tengo al final, después de estos 2 años?
Y seguramente lo primero que puedes decir es,
"Oye Sal, esto es demasiado sencillo, pues
empiezo con 100 pesos, crece un 25% y después
se encoge un 25%, pues acabo con 100 pesos"
Pero, hay que tener mucho cuidado porque no
es lo mismo, si dices que esa es la respuesta,
estarías en un error.
Porque fíjate bien, aunque es la misma tasa de interés,
no es a la misma cantidad de dinero
a la que se le aplica.
En un principio vamos a sacar el 25% de 100
pesos, pero en el segundo año lo que vamos
a hacer es restarle el 25% no a 100 pesos,
sino a lo que nos salga en el primer año.
Al resultado de 100 pesos después de que
creció un 25% en el primer año.
Es decir, en el primer año obtenemos 125 pesos,
el 25% de 100 pesos es 25 pesos, pero en el
segundo año cuando se encoge nuestro dinero,
cuando cae todo esto, va a pasar lo siguiente,
lo que hay que calcular es el 75% o .75 de
125 pesos,
muy parecido a lo que vimos en el ejercicio anterior.
Si mi dinero cae 25%, es exactamente lo mismo
que quedarnos solamente con el 75% de lo que
tenemos de dinero, pero ojo, no de los 100 pesos, de los 125 pesos que obtuve en el primer año,
así que vamos a calcularlo.
Me queda 5 por 5 = 25 y llevamos 2, 5 por
2 = 10 más 2 son 12 llevamos 1, 5 por 1 = 5
más 1 son 6, después pongo un 0 aquí,
7 por 5 = 35 y llevamos 3, 7 por 2 = 14 más 3 son 17,
17 no 14 y ehhh... después llevamos 1,
7 por 1 = 7 más 1 son 8
y entonces vamos a sumar esto, 5, 7, 6 y 4...
no, no, no... 6 y 7 son 13 y llevamos 1,
1 y 8 son 9... 93.75.
entonces la respuesta de esto es 93.75.
Y date cuenta que esto es mucho menor a lo
que empezamos, empezamos con 100 pesos y ahora
solamente tenemos 93.75 pesos, disminuyó
nuestro dinero, así que aunque la respuesta
más lógica parece ser que son 100 pesos,
no es así, si el primer año aumenta nuestro
dinero en un 25% y el siguiente año disminuye
nuestro dinero en un 25%,
realmente estamos perdiendo dinero.
Bastante interesante este ejercicio y de hecho
también bastante interesante pensar qué
es lo que pasa con acciones y algunas de estas
cosas, sin embargo eso lo voy a ver en otros
videos, ahorita no te quiero meter mucho en eso.
Pero bueno todo tiene sentido con esto del
dinero, cuando sube y cuando baja
o tal vez otra idea interesante sería preguntarnos,
¿cuál es el porcentaje que tendríamos que disminuir para llegar otra vez a los 100 pesos?
Pero bueno, eso lo podrías pensar tú en
un futuro y lo que quiero que veas es que
ya estás preparado para cualquier tipo de
problema que tenga que ver con porcentajes.
Espero que te hayas divertido.
Así que nos vemos en el siguiente video, adiós.